stranger things season 4 has the best of
everything when it comes to 80s wardrobe
makeup and hairstyles as well as creepy
prosthetics this means thousands of
hours dedicated to the makeup chair that
we're taking a little peek behind the
scenes at number one even vecna's claw
is all practical effects vechna is 90
prosthetics jamie campbell bauer had to
have
2425 different appliances on him when
they initially tested the prosthetic it
took them roughly eight and a half hours
but they managed to whittle that down to
six so for a 7 am start time he would be
in the chair at 1am
every part of him was covered in some
way he had dentures over his teeth that
looked rotten and blackened he had
contact lenses and vecna's left hand was
also done with practical effects using a
metal framework the only thing that was
really done in post was his veins or
vines or whatever you want to call them
number two it takes effort to get that
no effort look eleven was going for hi
guys i'm getting ready to go to work i'm
just waiting on my
coffee
while it may not seem like jane sorry 11
puts much work into her outfits behind
the scenes is a whole other story i
think it takes about i'd say an hour
why is that the case when she barely
wears any makeup the most i have is a
bit of mascara and some blush well out
of all the young cast millie bobby brown
takes the longest a full hour to get
ready because of her wig yeah we need to
find out an outfit that i get arrested
in
i've never thought i'd ever have to say
that
and millie and noah have way too much
energy for it being early in the morning
hey
good morning
you know who doesn't seem like a morning
person who we bet finds this peppy
enthusiasm annoying joe kiri
number three you'd think if you were
possessed the last thing you'd see is
white the white contacts were no picnic
wearing them was described as being in a
bright white room all by yourself the
first time the actors put on the white
contacts the costume designer filmed
their experience to try and make it an
event and take the stress off their
inability to see properly oh maybe they
put contacts on you yeah were they
uncomfy yeah number four there isn't
enough money in the world somebody could
offer us to do this role
robert england played victor creel who
once in costume could neither speak nor
see
and his hands were bound to the chair he
could only communicate through yes or no
questions and nods it took him about two
hours in the makeup chair he just loved
telling the makeup artists who were huge
fans of his work as freddy krueger
stories he's incredibly comfortable with
all the materials after years of using
them so he knew what they were all for
he knew when to close his eyes and turn
his head and the makeup artists just
loved him number 5.
gayton's invented a whole new hairstyle
called hat hair supreme
headed up to my trailer looks like the
sun is still just rising so gate and
moderazzo definitely didn't have to
spend six hours in a chair i'm about to
go get ready put on my uniform
let's get it
gayton is sent home with some really
amazing skin care products
and i never use them and you might not
have known his hair is perfectly slicked
back under that hat and it looks
ridiculous we don't know that could be a
style you know like a horizontal mullet
situation business on top dustin takes
just slightly more time than finn he's
in the 20-25 minute range but if he has
a cap on which he usually does then it
takes even less time gayton's character
dustin has been starting to put more
effort into his looks too they're a
faucet spray yeah fair fuss if you're
hoping to get steve's luscious long
locks you're out of luck the product is
no longer produced i should probably go
to work now
number six finn basically gets to roll
out of bed and right on to the set
hi finn has it easy compared to all the
actors who take ages getting prosthetics
on yeah i become like in 20 minutes it's
about the time so i think you might be
the fastest right now well he's
competing for best time with another
member of the cast can you guess who
number seven david had a major
transformation from season three to four
then back to three again briefly david
must be the
now must be the the shortest okay but
he's covered in dirt and prosthetics he
doesn't have as much hair though this
season makeup makeup david was prepping
long before shooting began because he
had to trim down his dad bod to look
like the roughed up malnourished hopper
we see this season for flashback
purposes harbour had to get decked out
in prosthetics again because his face
just looked too thin harbor's pretty
comfortable with gaining and losing
weight for roles this is not even close
to the first time he's done it although
we bet putting on the weight is much
more fun
number 8.
best wig award goes to joseph quinn
yes this was the wig
and eddie munson the character that we
never knew we needed out of stranger
things number nine then they placed it
on his head and he became dustin
henderson a lot of people don't realize
that the hat was never planned it was
never meant to be such a defining
character trait we just went to the
fitting rooms one day and then they had
some baseball cap not just gayton all of
the characters were trying on hats and i
put one on i was like that's funny they
did it for one photo a goofy hat for one
shot and it just stuck the rest is
history
number ten do those suction cup things
actually stick or not why is it so giant
i didn't realize i'm big an oversized
arrow on your forehead all day would get
pretty annoying we bet
number 11. answer revealed finn is tied
with sadie for being such low
maintenance perhaps that's because
everyone but the sadie sink is decked
out in wigs and prosthetics and makeup
and she's still just the cool skater kid
who doesn't really care plus her natural
hair is gorgeous why would you cover
that up she only takes 20 minutes to get
ready too hair is typically 10 minutes
makeup is five minutes and that's
another five for costume it's seriously
just not fair to the others it's not
that bad we would guess noah would be
pretty quick too but alas the poor boy
is wigged he'd be more in the milly
department
number 12. the lost boy can be found
buried beneath dirt and sugar cornelius
made a small appearance but left a
lasting impression on all of us his
makeup was inspired by lost boys and one
small detail we appreciate is that they
put lip gloss on his lips to make it
look like he'd been eating sticky candy
the dirt is in the details
number 13. the return of dakor means the
return of more ridiculous prosthetics
for him if the gooey prosthetics mess at
the end of the day is any indication of
how nasty the application process was
it had two equal early mornings and they
not only had to do all these prosthetics
on daycare they also had to duplicate
them on his stunt double imagine having
double the work because the actors are
too valuable to break
number 14. we call this one road rash
chic we adore seeing a sleepy joe
pre-far a faucet wandering in to get his
day started
his road rash prosthetics were done by
autonomous fx the prosthetics look
disgusting if we do say so ourselves
good job team number 15. these wee beans
were all having fun the whole shoot it's
too bad their characters weren't it's no
secret that all of the patients in the
asylum looked just a bit sickly and
peter ballard is no exception the goal
was to suck the life out of their skin
and they did that with a color
correcting cream intended to neutralize
redness outside of jamie campbell bower
the patients also got an added layer of
wrinkle fx makeup number 16 wigs are at
least 30 percent of the personality of
this show look at my
wig
fabulous fit kara who plays karen
wheeler got to wear an awesome wig this
season the very vogue look of 1986 it's
cut with shorter layers on top to show
off that fabulous perm the look was
inspired by cape capshaw in indiana
jones and the temple of doom
number 17 would you cut your hair for a
roll grace had her hair cut for the role
of chrissy nothing over the top they
just trimmed it a bit shorter to give it
some beautiful volume she had it dyed
with highlights to match the topper wig
which are used to add volume to thin
hair number 18. sometimes simple is best
agent harmon the man who gets shot
trying to move the kids to safety had to
deal with a ton of blood the makeup
artist said this was a fun bloody mess
of a makeup we bet it wasn't too
difficult though less gutsy than some of
their other stuff daker we're looking at
you number 19. why does this one give us
scarecrow vibes it's the nose definitely
the nose
even without cgi this would make for a
fun halloween costume
number 20. we wish there were more shows
set in the 80s the aesthetic is just
perfect if you ask us it screams fun
something that is totally lacking in
this generation
if you watched over 60 of our videos
you'd finally arrive at the time it took
for jamie campbell bauer to get into his
prosthetic suit while that sounds like
an ideal way to spend a day you should
probably go and enjoy some sunshine were
you blown away by the style they brought
to stranger things this season let us
know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things